welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and while Marvel Studios has pushed
a number of films Avengers Kang Dynasty
and Avengers Secret Wars remain but will
Avengers King Dynasty remain or will we
get like a bigger Secret Wars part one
and part two how are we going to get to
Secret Wars what's the best path to take
well in my recent interview with Iman
volani she hinted at a future MCU that
could tie comic story lines with
elements from Deadpool 3 and Fantastic 4
Thunderbolts while neatly transitioning
away from maybe Jonathan maj's Kang the
Conqueror without sacrificing
storytelling is there still a place for
Kang in the MCU we think so Iman
definitely has a good pitch and Hector
and I have thoughts that's right because
this is a sneak peek where we're taking
the temperature of whatever we're
watching while we head the next episode
or look ahead in the next week of nerdom
and Hector Naro is here hey Hector how
you doing I'm so good I'm in my garage
surrounded by my comic so I'm the most
qualified person to be here yes that's
all it takes if you're ever feeling
impostor syndrome any YouTuber out there
just put a bunch of a wall of or Funko
Pops or toys and then people will just
know that you're an expert that's it
absolutely that's all it takes that's it
we really got to talk about this um and
uh Hector I know from an amazing video
you made for new rock stars breaking
down this comic storyline that you
really do know the Jonathan Hickman time
Runs Out storyline leading into the 2015
Secret Wars that they're seeming to
adapt right now in the MCU little bit
yeah I'm a little familiar with that
comic books yes I would say a little bit
or a lot of it that was a really good
analysis that you did of it thank you
thank you um but I highly recommend
everyone read those uh read those issues
of comics because it is uh one of the
best comic events that they've done but
it's complicated there's so many moving
parts to it um but uh just you know to
give a I'm not even GNA bother with the
summary but it really just starts with a
character named molecule man who is
discovered to be kind of a doomsday
device in every single universe that
spells out its destruction yeah so in
order to prevent that from happening we
have to identify and find all the
molecule men Dr Doom is involved with
this we find out that the beyonders were
really instrumental in placing them
there the beyonders kind of want this to
happen is that correct Hector yeah I
think that there is a lot of complex and
big ideas but ultimately what these
comic book stories mean to the
characters is that you have characters
like the Fantastic 4 you have characters
like The Avengers Spider-Man's plural
get wrapped up into this that are
dealing with the ends of their realities
and at first they're trying to pinpoint
the source of that they're trying to
figure out why certain parallel
universes and parallel realities in this
Multiverse are dying and getting snuffed
out and then you've got characters like
uh Reed Richards and and tala like
putting their heads together putting
their smarts together finding the source
unraveling this mystery but ultimately
just trying to survive these incursions
is what they're called um the Illuminati
is of course involved neyar the
Submariner is involved and I'm saying
all these characters and it's like a lot
of them are already in play in the
Marvel movies which is really cool a lot
of them have already hinted at this kind
of stuff with Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness outright saying
incursions are happening you know with
multiversal uh implications so that
story line was um was epic and cool and
had some great moments and It ultimately
ended with the end of everything and
then it went right into this um really
crazy ambitious miniseries called Secret
Wars which we know may or may not be the
inspiration for the sixth Avengers film
that's going to come out so yeah there's
a lot happening it's definitely
manageable and readable if you go and
read it all but um you may just be
reading certain sections and meeting
with certain characters and being like
what who's Hyperion and they just G to
keep reading like there's just so much
happening yes uh and you know and we'll
see we'll see if it's going to be the
sixth Avengers film or if they'll move
it up to the fifth Avengers film or if
they'll just like they they plan on this
being two separate events and they were
going to have two different titles but
they're just going to retitle the movie
and then make it like a Prelude chapter
I I want to bring in Iman valani though
because like she if she wasn't a famous
Avenger movie star she could be a
YouTuber breaking this stuff down that's
how knowledgeable she is about about how
this works and she had an amazing pitch
for how they could incorporate Kang into
this storyline so let's you and I react
to it Hector I think it's a really
really great seems like they're adapting
Hickman's storyline at least from an
Outsiders point of view I assume you're
siloed out of some of those
conversations but hypothetically you
know looking at things happening right
now if the you know the studio order
established the mcu's take on Kang as
the equivalent of molecule man from that
storyline that's what I was trying to
tell everyone okay okay okay this is
we're having a real interview right now
this is my we're just nerding out okay
you finish your thought and then and
then I'll I'll tell you what like my
theories are cuz I'm I genuinely am not
priv to any of these conversations great
so we can just we can just uh nerd out
on this I love it okay okay great Kang
equals molecule man at least in the way
structurally that story works I I agree
I agree he is like the doomsday device
of all these different realities and
then God Emperor Doom comes in to pick
up the pieces and build battle world out
of the Void that's what I'm that's what
I want to see happen but I'm I'm not in
control this franchise what version of
this are you most excited to see as a
comic reader and as a fan okay okay so
my my theories because it's like okay
the time runs out and like Secret Wars
it's a lot of characters and a lot of
storylines and I had to reread it twice
myself like just to understand the basis
of it so Translating that into film
would be near impossible I think without
it being super clunky and and then you
have so many new characters and a lot of
the new characters that are being
introduced they don't exactly exist in
the comics or they different versions of
them so I think it would make sense for
yes K to be a version of the molecule
man where he you know like ow re's
existing in every single universe and
there's different variants of him we've
already seen that so that makes sense
yep but also I feel like he could be he
could be the molecule man and the
beyonder all at once that actually makes
a lot of sense because Beyond there was
a king Prime like or something that that
had the ultimate power and and you know
because because molecule man absorbs the
Beyond's powers and gives it to doom and
who gives it to Reed Richards right so
if if you like cut out a couple
middlemen and it's just Kang and then
maybe there's a different version of
Kang that like is the main Mulan that's
like helping maybe it's even like a
Victor timley type who's like kind of
more innocent and wants to help doom and
he's the one who absorbs the other
molecule men and the beyonders powers
okay the big Kang or they kill all the
kings and they're they they they meet
their big boss and that's King prime or
something that's that's how I see it and
then the rest of the times out uh thing
can play out the same I think I love
that we have to bookmark this because
last time we were like speculating I'm
telling two weeks later they came out
and said Secret Wars was happening so
okay when we start maybe we're
manifesting something here right we're
we're willing it I again again wouldn't
you just watch Iman valani running her
own like Marvel Theory YouTube channel
like best the best running her own
studio is more like it let's just go
ahead and give her that title whenever
Kevin feige decides to retire so she
needs to be in the Brain Trust I think
like put her on put her give her a seat
at the table Yeah so I I don't want to
speak on behalf of Iman U because I
think she has this figured out but
really I B I think she is saying to cut
out a lot of the middleman because when
you read time runs out there are so many
steps yes um of like this level of
character who are reporting to this
character who are trying to defend
against this character so just to kind
of remove all of that infrastructure and
instead just kind of make it
a Kang Prime who is the beyonder who is
uh who is using other like Kang variants
as these doomsday devices as the kind of
molecule man and just rather than saying
like one character absorbs another's
character's power they're all just KS
who are doing it it's all part of that
Kang hierarchy that dog pile um and that
you use Kang Dynasty or any other title
whether it's fantastic 4 anything to
show that um that kind of in Game Theory
there's a concept called the Pirate game
in which like the most senior pirate
tricks the more Junior Pirates to
fighting against each other uh in
different kind of scenarios to try to
maximize his profit his share of the
buried treasure um and uh and so you
have like the pirate king who's trying
to and that's kind of like what we can
imagine Kang is applying right now he's
applying this kind of game theory and
trying to play other kangs against each
other um we don't know who Kang Prime is
yet in the MCU it could be Kang the
Conqueror who gets sucked into that
probability storm at the end of P Mania
just because that paperwork in the TVA
it we were able to make out that it said
um whereabouts of suspect unknown so I
think that's like Marvel saying he's not
dead not dead yeah not dead I I think it
would be I think the way IM mortise
faram and um Scarlet Centurion were
introduced is like even though there's
an implied seniority with am mortise I
think they were all introduced as like
equally wacky goofball gangs yes so I
think they're going to cancel each other
out there's some other Kang Prime um I
guess like what Iman is saying is that
like to lead up to that secret Wars
event you need someone else who isn't
Doom yet you need and I think they
already have the pieces of Kang it's
just I think Marvel Studios is still
unsure what's going to happen with
Jonathan major trial I just think that
would be a whatever happens with that
trial is just a silly reason to scrap
all the work they've done with Kang so
far I agree I think that um when the
infinity Saga was playing
out you know people there's a lot lot of
revisionist history happening right now
online where people are going back and
they're like the infinity Saga was
Flawless every step perfectly executed
and planned out uh no it was not very
much disagree there yes absolutely and I
think that that was such a a series of
happy accidents good accidents happy
accidents but even the notion that
Thanos was going to be the the endgame
the big bad wasn't in their mind early
on and I feel that because of the
success and the reception to a character
like Thanos Marvel Studios for their
next a was like well we should we should
we should really call this one you know
from the from
the home base here home plate early as
we can we should really call it it's
going to be king Kang the Conqueror
that's our big bad for the Multiverse
Saga and I think based on the reception
critically and financially to the last
few movies and to Ant-Man of the WASP
Quantum Mania Marvel Studios May
reconsider that in pivot but it also may
have always been part of the plan I
think I can see it both ways I can see
it where Marvel was fully committed on
Kang as being the Thanos uh going all
the way through Secret Wars going all
the way through the Multiverse Saga and
then maybe the reception of the
character again exclude for a second the
the actor's um legal trial like if that
ends up being a a a really bad situation
I think that Marvel should absolutely
recast the character and I've seen
people online say well Marvel has an
issue with recasting characters look at
Black Panther but Chadwick Boseman
passed away due to cancer is a very
different scenario than like one of
their actors May potentially allegedly
be abusive that's a that's a completely
different so I think it's it's it's
absolutely would be appropriate and fine
and okay to recast Kang if they wanted
to commit with Kang so going back to
what I was saying a second ago one of
those two scenarios is either they see
the reception of Kang and they go oh
people don't really love him the way
they loved Thanos maybe we should sort
of pivot a little bit but the second
scenario is they were already always
planning to do that in the Multiverse
Saga because Secret Wars and Dr Doom go
together like peanut butter and jelly
they have to kind of be elements of that
huge story and Dr Doom is such a massive
Monumental character to Marvel he is as
big as Loki or Magneto or Thanos in
terms of villainous Marvel characters in
the universe so I think that Marvel is
always planning has always been looking
at how are we going to bring Doom into
this how is how are we going to set this
character up to have that longevity that
these other Loki and Thanos type
characters have had not to knock Kang
the Conqueror but to me he's always been
a little bit of a beist Avengers
character like he's a big threat he's
he's like an Ultron but some Avengers
villains don't necessarily have that
same sort of like popular appeal you
know the the wide reaching Marvel
Universe um threat that like a Thanos or
like a Dr Doom has in my opinion even
though Doom is definitely a fantastic
for villain I've always felt like Kang
is somebody who despite how powerful he
is he keeps getting defeated by The
Avengers you know and I think that's
something that's present in quantam
Mania right wrer Jeff lovess make sure
to like bring that up is like this is a
guy who's GNA continue to lose and lose
and lose and what does that do to a
character and you know does it make him
angry and this and that so um I think
Marvel knows that about Kang so I feel
like they were always always planning to
bring in Dr Doom it was just a matter of
when yeah I think um I think Jeff lovess
everything he has said about what he
tried to do with Kang the Conqueror in
Quantum Mania shows me that he gets like
yeah he gets the character and he and he
gets what the character could be and
that's why I was so bummed to hear that
like these rumors that they may just be
scrapping whatever his vision was
because to show that like he would have
to leave rather than they could just
give him the note means that he was so
embedded in whatever that story was that
he couldn't extract himself from it and
come with something new and I'm just
dying to read whatever treatment or
draft you came up with um but the issue
I think is not with the writing I think
a lot of people blame the writing it's
more of like the way these characters
were structured in the bigger top level
decisions and what titles to introduce
them in and I think it might have been a
mistake to introduce Kang the Conqueror
on the big screen in Ant-Man the was
Quanto Mania if that's the story you
wanted to tell right I think uh the way
the Kang mythology has been told in Loki
has been incredible
and nearly flawless I think the
character of he who remains as played by
Jonathan major and Victor timley as
played by Jonathan Majors have been
really good but for a lot of people they
just view Disney Plus shows as lesser
than and these trades variety deadline
Hollywood Reporter only care about
movies and if they if it's something
that happens on a streaming show it's
not as canonically or U budgetarily as
important uh which I just think is so
weird because I just think Loki has been
such important important storytelling to
the Marvel fan base and I think the
trades don't get that they just think
like it's this nothing show um they
think it's TV which is silly because
there are movie stars and movie
directors who are making TV and that's
been the case for 10 years yeah um
doesn't surprise me though it it is
unfortunate like you're saying that like
even if this isn't exactly what happens
in the movie it's a bummer that Marvel
Studios gave for lack of a better term
right now the haters uh the the the
notion that like their next big bad was
defeated by a bunch of ants that's not
really what happened but the haters are
going to keep repeating that over and
over and over again and it's like maybe
you're right Eric maybe it wasn't the
smartest move to even just include K in
an Ant-Man story period even if they're
trying to elevate Ant-Man in the WASP
these characters to give him a little
bit more serious Stakes which I super
appreciate it's still going to boil down
to fans of these movies haters of these
movies are going to say well he got
defeated by a bunch of ants he's not the
next Thanos that's a bummer that's a
real bummer yeah well and I think part
of the bummer is uh what you mentioned
the happy accidents of the infinity Saga
absolutely everyone read Joanna and
Gavin and Dave's book um MC the random
Marvel Studios it tells the story very
clearly that like a lot of this was just
happy accidents luck but also just some
like smart flexibility on the part of
Kevin feige um and you know like they
made a lot of smart choices and part of
it was like they introduced Thanos in
small doses and they never said they
didn't announce the infinity Saga until
we had already been living with Josh
Brolin's uh Thanos for at least one
post-credit scene right uh Jos Sweden
threw him in with a stunt actor I
believe playing Thanos looking out at
Earth or you know looking out at a
broken planet um the wonderful Daman
patier stunt actor he's he was in Star
Trek JJ Abrams Star Trek he's he was in
the he he played gold gold face in the
flash he's a fantastic actor and uh and
was featured in a lot of Jos Weeden uh
projects back in the day but um is
somebody who yeah is uh he was that
early Thanos and they went in a
different direction and did that whole
CG thing but he was wearing makeup which
is crazy for that is crazy thank you
thank you for remembering his name um
and then uh we had Josh Brolin in
Guardians of the Galaxy uh and so like
he was in these small roles but every
time we saw him he was doing this cool
scary he said I will bathe the G I
will bathe the stars in your blood right
he's like fine I'll do it myself there
wasn't a whole lot right and instead
they uh like we got to see I believe
Jonathan major and Loki which was great
but like I don't think they had already
planned like pton Reed cast him for
quantam Mania like quantam Mania was the
first play and they didn't have a good
Kang story in Quantum Mania that was
like not a great introduction to the
character at all um like if you really
wanted to introduce Kang properly you
should introduce the guy as like in the
background of everything we've seen in
the MCU just pull a quick Montage or
just one scene like you could like just
show the same shot you have of the
schwarma restaurant of the guy sweeping
and then someone say hey Johnny can you
go grab the extra whatevers and then
he's like the stock boy in the back and
Jonathan major who's like I'm on it you
know like you just do little like
that just s of like every iconic moment
of the MCU just like just like Jake
Gyllenhaal with barf how he would this
they stuck him into Civil War in the
background okay like Forest Gump they
digitally inserted him into some shots
of Captain America Civil War great I
don't I don't know if that would have
worked better but like as they post
credit to something I think that would
have been a really fun introduction yeah
the the other thing too I don't know if
we're missing this and it necessarily
matters but I know that from being a fan
of the comics the first time I learned
about Kang the Conqueror you learn that
he is a a descendant of Reed Richards
right and it's like I wonder if maybe
having a fantastic forign to Reed
Richards first and then an introduction
to a character who goes I'm from the
31st Century I'm Nathaniel Richards oh
cool this guy's a good guy wrong he's
the worst type of bad guy and then kind
of go from there um if that would have
maybe hit harder or that would have um
uh gotten people to get a little bit
more because as of right now the the
connection that this character has right
Thanos was gamor nebula's Dad that was
the connection to the rest of the Marvel
heroes and right now Kang the
conqueror's connection is like he's from
the future and there's a bunch of
variant and he wants to he's killed
Avengers before and he kind of lives in
all the and there's really no did he
have a relationship with Ant-Man did he
have a relationship with the WASP did he
have a relationship with Loki not
necessarily so maybe that's another
reason that this character quite hasn't
connected to or stuck in audien's heads
I guess yeah you make you bring up a
really good point like for an effective
villain has to have like a personal
relationship with the hero and the
trailers for Quanto Mania hinted that
you know this guy had killed Avengers
before we didn't see that we still have
not seen that right we haven't even seen
like any trophies that he might have
collected from any Avengers like Marvel
will not pull the trigger on making Kang
an actual villain so you know what bad
habits have a bad habit of sticking
around fighting them is hard but
transforming something like Doom
scrolling from a bad habit to a good one
is easy thanks to fume fume makes it
possible to replace your bad habits with
good ones that you are free to enjoy
it's an Innovative award-nominated
device with no electronics no vapor and
no harmful chemicals fume is completely
natural and it uses all natural
ingredients to give you a burst of
delicious flavored air and fume is super
fidgety which is helpful for
de-stressing while you break your old
habit each device has an adjustable
airflow dial and it's designed with
movable parts and magnets using fume
just gives you a nice moment just for
yourself crisp mint makes my brain think
I'm sitting on a porch sipping a julip
and maple pepper gives me a strong
weakened brunch Vibe even if I'm just
waiting to cross the street and working
moments like that into your routine is a
good habit stopping is all something we
put off because it's hard but switching
to fume is easy enjoyable and even fun
fume has served over 150,000 customers
and has thousands of success stories and
there's no reason you can't be one of
them join fume in accelerating
Humanity's breakup from destructive
Habits by picking up the journey pack
today head to Tri
fum.fi
10% off your order today in my head my
favorite version of the Kang story does
come from comic books that came out
while I was in high school it's an
unfair Advantage but that's the
advantage they get Young Avengers
introduces the team of characters who
have to form an Avengers because there
isn't one because they've been disbanded
they were disassembled and one of those
characters is iron lad and then the
twist is he's Nathaniel Richards but
younger and he doesn't want to be evil
and that character had connection to
Cassie Lang they shared a romance that
character had connection to the rest of
the Young Avengers so when that betrayal
happened I was devastated I was Allin
when adult Kang shows up and goes no you
have to be Kang you have to follow
through with your destiny to be evil and
I thought that was a really compelling
story so for me whenever Avengers the
King Dynasty was announced I thought
that's what the movie was going to be it
wasn't going to be Captain America Sam
Wilson forming a new team of Avengers it
was going to be Kamala Khan recruiting
Kate Bishop recruiting Cassie Lang
recruiting Eli Bradley you know whatever
other Young Avengers characters we've
got there maybe uh a reincarnated Tommy
and Billy to then go up against or or
rather an iron lad shows up you get this
great young black actor to play Iron lad
people are like this the new Iron Man
and you don't reveal in the trailers
what the twist is he's a Kang variant
and and you have the Kang character be
the villain in that film who shows up
and just completely breaks the hearts of
all of the Young Avengers characters
that we love and we're all of a sudden
on the side of that and that movie could
have been the sort of infinity War to
Thanos where I know people thought he
was really cool in the chair but I
remember people also making fun like all
he does is sit in a chair the Thor short
made fun with Thor's like all he does is
sit in this purple guy all he does is
sit in a chair so it wasn't until
Infinity war came out that people went
oh this guy is serious this guy's
an awesome villain maybe the Kang
Dynasty that's what they're reserving
Kang for um but then again we already
got an entire movie and two seasons of a
show with him in it so yeah I think the
Young Avengers is one really great path
that they could have explored cuz that
is very personal one's own sense of
Destiny and his Rel relationship to
trying to rebuild the Avengers I get
that I think another path is the fact
that he is a descendant of Reed Richards
and you make him you just tell the
events of the Fantastic 4 number 19 you
know like he is one of the earliest
Fantastic 4 villains now I know I'm
doing like historical revisionism right
now but if you know the infinity Saga is
coming to an end it's like 2017 2018
Marvel's already making its plans for
Beyond they don't know that CO's coming
but then they go in front of the ComiCon
audience in 2019 was it the smartest mov
move to say we don't have time for
mutants or Fantastic 4 let's talk about
the eternals let's talk about doctor
strange and for 11 Thunder how Natalie
Portman's coming back to Thor like is
that really like the smartest moves in
retrospect like why not say no we're
going to lead with Fantastic 4 Kang is
going to be the villain to them Kang has
a familial ancestral relationship with
Reed Richards and that's going to be the
dawn of our new big bad and also here's
Natalie Portman she's also here too but
mainly be there too but like they talked
about like remember the big headlines
were Natalie Portman mersel Ali's blade
and then an eternals movie and then yes
shung XI too yes not to say we can't
have all of these things but they said
yes to all these projects that like
Marvel fans weren't really asking for
right I mean it's it's it's a tricky
thing because Marvel Studios was in a
position where they're looking ahead
they're looking behind them and they
went it took us 10 years to do this and
one could say that maybe they got to
Thanos too early could they have spaced
out out some of these stories in these
characters and and um you know gotten
more movies out of some of these
characters and made even more billions
of dollars I don't know I don't know
what when they're when they look back on
what they've done what they think they
should have done differently because we
love all those movies but maybe they
were looking ahead and going you know
instead of just trying to do and
thankfully they didn't do this movie
movie movie Avengers movie movie movie
Avengers you know each of those is going
to be a phase let's refocus let's
rethink about this introduce new
characters to further you know stretch
out our our longevity and our our
interest in our films and everything um
because maybe they did look behind and
went we went through three Captain
America movies three Iron Man movies
three Thor movies in these first in this
first 10 years and maybe we'll get a
Thor four and maybe they'll be a new
Captain America but I'm sure they were
looking at that stuff and going people
love those characters and they'll
certainly love the new characters were
going to introduce and a new iteration
of an Iron Man maybe like an iron heart
and a new iteration of cap absolutely
Sam Wilson but maybe they were also a
little bit nervous of like maybe we got
to some of this stuff and this kind of
universe ending stuff a little too quick
I don't know I mean maybe they didn't
have enough um time to spend with once
they had gotten the rights because of
the fox and Disney merger with uh the
Fantastic foreign X-Men for them to
definitively declaratively State what
they were going to do with them what the
movies were going to look like and you
know it's tough because I for one really
love all that extra stuff it feels very
70s Marvel to me in the comic books you
know the 60s was Banger after Banger
after Banger it was Stanley and Jack
Kirby at the height of their game just
introducing all the most iconic
characters and then in the 70s after
Jack Kirby left Marvel Stan Lee left to
become like a producer and or editor and
chief or whatever he was doing you know
he moved to Los Angeles I believe in the
70s and 80s shopping stuff around to do
TV shows like the Incredible Hulk there
there was still a great creative output
but they've refocused they're like what
about horror what about man thing what
about you know Ghost Rider all these
cool funky 70s characters Wolverine was
introduced in that decade and I think
that it kind of took them another 10
years or so going into the 80s before
they can kind of settle back into like
okay now we know what the X-Men are now
we know what the Fantastic Four is doing
Thor's killing it with this Walt
Simonson run so that's this is what
Marvel feels like to me right now but I
can imagine it's it's I understand that
it's frustrating for non-comics fans to
be like where's all my favorite
characters because they don't understand
that Marvel Comics like always has your
favorite character they're just always
there or some iteration of them or
whatever so um yeah it was maybe not the
smartest thing to to to just that early
into it say The Multiverse Saga that's
what we're doing because we're seeing it
right now we're seeing that maybe they
might shift and and and change course
yeah look I'm all for the
experimentation I just think Marvel
Studios would use the things that they
really were treating as experimentation
as like tent poles
and I I think I think internally at the
studio they didn't know what their tent
poles were and what their experiments
were and in some cases the executive
producers who were assigned to those
experiments were like I'm going to do
everything I can to make this a tent
pole because I want to come back as I
want to get a pay bump I want to make my
thing essential so they would like tell
all the showrunners to like put this in
put this in and yeah I got it approved
so great and then Kevin feig's like I'm
overseeing 18 different things right now
yes yes to everything and then we get
like crazy things that happened in W
division really great things that happen
in Loki we have crazy thing we have uh
Kingpin showing up in in hawkey um and
some of it leads to great stuff coming
back but a lot of it just leads to
confusion um now I I just think like had
they gone into phase four and five with
like we're going to experiment with some
stuff but we're going to have our tent
poles um and that 2019 announcement had
no real tent poles especially in
retrospect like I think Multiverse of
Madness was treated as a tent pole but
like clearly there was no communication
between the Multiverse Madness team and
the W division team uh and like we got
no real villain coming out of that we
just got like a different version of
Reed Richards telling us about
incursions now maybe in a couple years
from now we'll learn that that
conversation was very important but
again a couple years from now some of us
are gonna be
dead like this shirt says we're all
gonna
die anyway i' I'm obviously I I'm just
trying to speak to I think the confusion
and the frustration because what's at
stake here what we didn't get the movies
we wanted as fast as we wanted no what's
at stake here is like now Marvel has
painted itself into a corner in this
kind of PR headache of like putting all
their hopes on Jonathan major one actor
to carry this franchise when they
haven't written really good storylines
for him in the movies right they've
relied on the Loki writing staff to come
up with some amazing dialogue and some
amazing philosophies for this character
but because the way the industry works
the way it does those will always be
seen as less than and less loadbearing
as Quantum media yeah I agree and then
you've got the Great M Marvel TV show
but people the trades everybody sees it
as less than going into the big movie
the Marvels which is a real bummer
because Aman's brilliant in the show and
in the movie and and I love her ideas of
of trying to cut out that middleman I
think that um the notion of having a
character in these movies that has that
has the role of a molecule man I think
is really important you got to have an
insanely powerful character who is maybe
a little naive and maybe easily
manipulatable and maybe that could be a
Kang maybe that could be Scarlet Witch I
know you've talked about this before
kind of being a Nexus being maybe it
could be a Loki the Loki variant from
the TVA is somebody who could you know
think he's doing something
altruistically but somebody like a Dr
Doom like steals his power there's a lot
of stuff they could do with that and the
the the bummer of it is is that I love
the idea of having molecule man be a
crappy bad guy that the Fantastic 4 just
kind of quickly deals with but then that
character comes back later and everyone
goes oh molecule man's a huge
threat really really off the deep end
this is a really scary character really
scary idea but I like that history of
them being like a C or D list bad guy
that even though is so powerful doesn't
really know what to do with that power
kind of like I think Electro Falls in
that same category for Spider-Man maybe
the most powerful like Spider-Man
villain but Max Dylan always gets in his
own way like he's just kind of a normal
dude so he doesn't know what to you know
he's not that ambitious or whatever so
maybe we'll get that in fantastic for
maybe Fantastic 4 will introduce us a
great actor playing molecu man and then
we won't see them and then the main bad
guy will be moleman or Dr Doom or Silver
Surfer Galactus or somebody and then in
secret Wars that molecule M character
comes back but I like am man's pitch too
to to have that be a Kang instead I
think would be a great shortcut I agree
um now we should do a quick heat check
on how we're feeling about the
Multiverse Saga and what could come
Beyond it before that though quickly I
just want to take this moment to tell a
check out nerd rot. shop where you can
always grab the latest and greatest new
rockstars gear we just uh put up this
wonderful best bubs shirt inspired by
Deadpool 3 that you can grab as a
holiday season officially kicks into
gear that shirt looks amazing support
the channel and check out our great
merch options over at nerd rot. shop and
don't forget to subscribe to all three
channels in the new Rockstar network uh
including this channel new rockstars the
break room and the Deep dive but um
let's do a quick heat check so a lot of
thoughts about the Multiverse Saga right
now is this just how a Multiverse Saga
should feel should it feel kind of
chaotic about
amlin um and what what what Saga do you
want to see on the other side of it is
it time for just a mutant Saga on the
other side of this yeah listen I'm the
the the Dork who's going to say they've
got the rights to the X-Men just do it
right just take your time and do it
right and I will I will pitch that the
Saga after this should be the Phoenix
Saga now yeah I know Phoenix I know we
got a movie called Dark Phoenix I know
we had a movie X-Men the Last Stand that
tried to do it but I think that most
comic book fans would agree that that
those adaptations didn't really quite
cut the mustard but more so than that to
just focus on Phoenix focus on Gan gray
but focus on the X-Men characters over
an additional three sagas or three
phases rather so seven eight and nine
are going to be the X-Men focused
Phoenix Saga yeah you can bring in
characters like the Shar and the star
Jammers and and and more of the space
Cosmic stuff for it to culminate in that
kind of story but to plant the seeds and
to go early from like I would love to
see the X-Men in a movie introduced as
basically Peter Parker's age at least
that first class of X-Men right that
that that Cyclops Gan gray Beast Iceman
Angel and then their sequel movie is the
one that brings in the giant siiz X-men
group with h Colossus Nightcrawler storm
Wolverine Sunfire Thunderbird those
great characters Banshee those great
characters um and then maybe doing
Disney plus Series in between this is
all stuff that I feel like even writer
Chris Claremont pitched at a convention
at one point when a fan asked him
because you know the X-Men are at their
best when they're very soap opera when
you can kind of take your time with
these characters and the relationships
and I'd love to see the long game of you
know an entire generation grew up with
like seeing Anakin Skywalker fall to the
dark side or you know I think it would
be so cool if Marvel took years five 10
years to do like here's Jean Gray going
from like a teenage character like a
young person who's figuring out her
powers to maybe even destroying a planet
having to sacrifice herself just really
really tragic horrific stuff but maybe
even relooking at the Phoenix Saga in a
new light and seeing what we can do and
maybe giving the character uh more of a
Redemption I don't know but I would say
do the call it the Phoenix Saga to to
really get fans to go really we're doing
this again and then for Marvel to go
hang on let us cook let us cook you
don't know what we're going to do how
are we're going to do it that'd be my
pitch I I think that's a hot pitch
Hector I think uh after basic it's very
basic Eric it's not hot it's not a hot
pitch I think it's hot I think that
would be a very ballsy thing for them to
do especially after dark Phoenix which
Dean bani in our interview said she
doesn't she's not gonna watch it not
gonna watch it I get it but dark Phoenix
is not the worst X-Men movie y'all it's
not and it has a really Kick-Ass score
from Han Zimmer like it's really good um
what do you think is the worst X-Men
Origins Wolverine that's it that's the
worst one that's might be the most
disappointing that might be but it takes
but X-Men Origins Wolverine has some
crazy that happens in it will I am
is X or I mean that is it's an insane
movie uh whereas I it's hard to remember
anything about dark Phoenix yeah I just
listed the score I know it's tough
Jessica chastang was in it there's like
a cool she was a sh you mentioned the
Shar I believe she was a Shar but they
had to dial back the shape shifting
because it was going to be too scroll
like yeah which is a real bummer but you
know now Marvel can do everything right
I guess or do everything in a big
bombastic way um that'd be that'd be fun
I'd also put dark Phoenix over New
Mutants I didn't really love New Mutants
so you know there you go there's worse
Xmen that's all I'm saying there's worse
Xmen you guys come
on um we're gonna break down all of them
in the new year it doesn't matter if it
was new mut if it was dark Phoenix we'll
get to all of them in the New Year I'm
I'm not kidding we're doing all of them
here's my pitch and maybe you'll
disagree Eric but by the time you get to
them I think that the movie Dark Phoenix
no joke is better than X-Men the Last
Stand that's my hot take that's my hot
take sorry disagree with that disagree
with that cuz been the last stand is not
a good movie but it has I mean it h it's
I got you maybe I got you with that
maybe I got
you that's all I'm saying that's all I'm
saying I think the cast I mean look just
any scene that Hugh Jack was playing
Wolverine that's why it's like I always
just love him every time he's on screen
as Wolverine it's I'll always defend it
get I get it I get it I get it but you
know dark Phoenix it's I mean I think
what's I think you're you're barking up
the right tree though Hector because I
think what we need is a true mutant
Academy like we need just kind of what
X-Men um remember X-Men evolution sure
abut Fox kids like Banger show great
show um yeah yeah it had that's what
introduced x23 like right was3
introduced absolutely absolutely so what
we need is like a true mutant Academy a
true soap opera I believe gen v um did a
great example of what that could look
like um like we already have the table
set of the dodc and government forces
with Ritson and all them like
distrusting and wanting to lock up we
could just introduce Sentinels like
hunting I mean that's where if you watch
the fox animated 90s I mean it starts
right in the middle of like a sentinel
conflict like it's it doesn't take its
time at all so you could just introduce
that in live action I think without too
much effort just introduce the right
young people and kamalak Khan as a
mutant can be right in the middle of it
um that's I think where we need to see
Iman next oh that'd be amazing certainly
after Young Avengers I mean I I think
going back to this the the the
announcement day Eric that you were
talking about with Marvel and then
saying we we didn't even talk about
Fantastic 4 we didn't talk about mutants
the other thing I think is maybe they
have taken so much of their own time
because they looked ahead and they went
okay we can either jump right into our
own version of you know Logan Wolverine
and Charles Xavier and Magneto and uh uh
storm and all these characters or we can
take advantage of this Multiverse
concept we can do a Spider-Man movie
that pay pays tribute and says goodbye
to Toby Maguire and Andrew Garfield
Spider-Mans and we can do some X-Men
Centric stuff where we bring back Hugh
Jackman we bring back of course Ryan
Reynolds Deadpool was going to happen
but maybe they relooked at that and went
what a great opportunity to bring back
Hugh put him in the yellow costume you
know sort of pay tribute but say goodbye
to him and the rest of the Universe of
those uh Fox X-Men characters we've got
Patrick Stewart Charles Xavier which we
saw we may see again maybe not but said
goodbye to him in a way put him in that
iconic yellow hover chair and had played
the little theme we saw a sort of a CG
Beast you know with voed by Kelsey
gramar why not Nicholas Hol because I
think they're very purposely trying to
have this kind of like Elder versions of
the X-Men characters to differentiate
when they introduce their Hank McCoy
it's going to be a younger Hank McCoy
that's my take is that I think they're
looking at the m ver Saga and going
let's use this opportunity to to bring
in some Heavy Hitters with the fox X-Men
movies say goodbye and then sort of wipe
the Slate clean and then and do our own
version within the sacred timeline
within reality 616 that is our Charles
Xavier our school our young group of
students and then introducing our own
Wolverine at some point maybe Wolverine
versus Hulk I'm Still Holding Out for
that fight I think it's going to happen
but that's that could be another reason
that they sort of paused on just jumping
right into their own version of X-Men
yes oh for sure I I think that is what
the the X-Men reality that we are seeing
in the Marvel's post credit scene and in
uh Deadpool 3 I think is a temporary uh
it's a temporary X-Men universe that is
going to self-destruct this is not their
future this is just like a task force
Mission with one objective to get to
Secret Wars and it's like paratroopers
you're not building um a community of
Tomorrow you are building just a task
force to do one mission that is just
little bit longer than the xforce in
Deadpool 2 just a little bit longer but
it's going to have the same ending a lot
of these characters are going to be
killed off or just sealed off on the
other side of a Multiverse wall yeah
they're gonna meet OB and he's be like
we're all gonna die and they're gonna be
like yes we are we're all gonna die all
these X-Men characters y yeah for sure
yep we'll leave it there for this
episode of the sneak peek Hector what
this like we had other stuff planned
we're going to have to talk about that
in the future episode because like this
ended up just being such a good man mey
conversation we covered a lot of ground
here and I apprciate shout out to Aman
bani for really kickstarting that nerd
fire um I'm such a fan of hers and her
and her X-Men Kamala Khan comic is
fantastic highly recommend really really
good you want to talk about somebody who
gets the X-Men Iman valani gets the
X-Men so yeah be sure to I'm shouting
out her comic be sure to check that out
and also I want to thank the sponsor to
this video because I'm a little under
the weather vix Vapor Rub uh just a
fantastic product all around or as
Mexicans call it vix vaporu so go get
yourself some vix vaporu and try to heal
yourself this holiday SE if only we
could get Vick's money are you kidding
me they're going to see this and go like
wait a minute yeah nerds get stuffy
noses too let's go ahead and advertise
with these guys they're going to watch
minute 41 of this uh this podcast and
then yep you know who the who the real
rock stars are vix Vapor
up uh be sure to follow new rock stars
on all of our social media and uh all
three of our channels follow Hector at
Hector ISF funny and at here reforge and
you can follow me at eaos and uh we'll
see everybody next week thanks for
watching bye everybody bye Hector
[Applause]
[Music]
bye